[Music]
so
this dwelling the aspect of the
universal element or inorganic nature of
spirit
now also includes within it a shape of
individuality which brings nearer to
actuality
the spirit that previously was separated
from existence and was external or
internal to it
and thereby makes the work more in
harmony with active
self-consciousness the artificer lays
hold first of all of the form of being
for self in general of the animal shape
that he is no longer conscious of
himself immediately in animal life
he proves by constituting himself the
productive power in relation to it
and knows himself in it as in his work
whereby the animal shape at the same
time
becomes superseded in the hieroglyph of
another meaning of a thought
consequently the shape too is no longer
solely and entirely used by the
artificer but is blended with the shape
of thought
with the human form but the work still
lacks the shape and outer reality in
which the self exists
as self it still does not in its own
self
proclaim that it includes within it and
inner meaning
it lacks speech the element in which the
meaning filling
is it is itself present
therefore the work even when it is
wholly purged
of the animal element and wears only the
shape of self-consciousness
is is still the soundless shape which
needs the rays of the rising sun
in order to have sound which generated
by light
is even then merely noise and not speech
and reveals only an outer not the inner
self
because paragraph 695 focuses on the
artificers
appropriation of animal life you might
be tempted to say well that's
very similar to what was happening in
the paragraph
just earlier with plant life and now
we've got a nice
sequence we go from the understanding
and crystals to plant life
to animal life and we've essentially
reproduced the
progression that we've gone through
before
in in the substantive discussions in
natural religion and
yes that's all true and you should see
that as a sequence
but there's also some important
differences between what's going on in
this paragraph
and what happened in the earlier
paragraph 694
discussing the appropriation of plant
life so you know what are some of these
vital differences you notice one is
terminological
so hegel here is going to use the word
shape rather than just form gestalt
rather than form right and that is going
to be
important he's also going to talk in
terms of
auf heimong uh the you know the
sublation or however you want to talk
about it
here we have a supersession right of the
the animal shape so we've got a bit more
concrete you know dynamic stuff
happening here and and this is reflected
in what hegel is actually saying and
it's also reflected in the nature
of the material that we're working with
the
animal forms right the animality which
is
closer to humanity not least because we
are among the animals as classical
philosophy
reminds us so many times so let's take
up what he what he has to say here
he says this dwelling vonong in
in german right the aspect of the
universal element or inorganic nature of
spirit
now also includes within it a shape of
individuality which brings nearer to
actuality to
the spirit that was previously separated
from existence from from dozen and dozen
and vehicle kite two important terms
indicating
being you know actual being in the world
so spirit you could say was
not entirely able to get
out of our heads or out of abstractions
now
spirit is going to be present in the
world through
the incorporation of animality now
we just had that a few paragraphs back
though right the
you know tribes and peoples associating
themselves with particular
animals what's what's different here so
he tells us the artificer
um is going to be doing something
different here he talks about making the
work
more in harmony with
active self-consciousness who's the
active self-consciousness
the artificer it's and there's more
active self-consciousness involved in
being an artificer
in this way why well because
there's two parts this one is you are
more active by the very material that
you're working with because it's an
active material rather than a passive
material
right it's no longer just a inert
lifeless thing
it's no longer just plants that you know
okay they're living but they're not
sentient and they're not gonna you know
move around and try to wiggle away from
you
now you're dealing with active materials
and it's also the self
part of it that makes it more deep and
dynamic here
as well for spirit as the artificer
so he says this artificer lays hold
first of all
of the form of being for self in general
the animal
shape the animal gestalt and
if we go back to the previous two
paragraphs right
where we're talking about an in itself
or body
and then you know being in itself and
being for
itself or the soul and the goal is to
bring these two together
we have a different kind of in itself
here as a matter of fact there's no
mention
of the in itself which means that the in
itself has now become
being for itself but being for itself in
general
the animal shape why is the animal shape
being for itself
in general well because animals uh
you know although they don't have
individuality
uh being for itself in a hegelian sense
they certainly do have being for itself
in a general sense their entire
assemblage of
instincts and learned responses
to their environment you know dealing
with
being able to seek out food and
stay alive reproduction um
you know those that have some sort of
social
status component engage in those sorts
of things so there is being for itself
involved in animals and we also you
could say as human beings
give them and you see this in every
single culture that talks about
animals that personifies them that
brings them within to their
religious sphere according them a
certain being for
self right so
animal shape you know is
is a certain kind of being for self that
is what is being taken as the raw
material
now you might say well wait a second
isn't the raw material
the things that the artificer is working
in
like the wood or the bamboo
or the raffia or the you know cave
paintings the ochre
and other you know pigments and stuff
like that yeah yes
that's very true and that's that's
another element that's not being
discussed here
because we can just take it for granted
what is being
embodied what is being depicted
animality
so hegel goes on and he says
um that he is no longer conscious of
himself
immediately in animal life as he was
back
you know in paragraph 690
you know how do we know this well he
proves it by constituting
himself the productive power in relation
to it and knows himself
in it that is in uh animal life
right in his work where it whereby
the animal shape at the same time
becomes here we have it
superseded and the hieroglyph
of another meaning of a thought why talk
about hieroglyph here
that immediately suggests egyptians
doesn't it
well yes but hieroglyph is also a
general term that can refer to
egyptian hieroglyphs like those that we
find in burial chambers
but it can also be any other sort
of holy writing any
holy representation hiro glyph right
and so you know this could be cave
paintings this could be
other things as well and the animal
form as what it is in nature
is being alf-kohlben you know sublated
brought into a greater
unity by being represented by being uh
turned into you know fourstellang being
you know for gestalt being
placed there in front of us by the
artificer the artificer is the one who
knows
that he is doing this so hegel goes on
and he says
what does this mean well it becomes the
hieroglyph of another meaning
of a thought the artificer is a
thinker and we're getting closer and
closer to
more and more thought and reaching a
certain you might say critical mass
or threshold so he says
the shape is no longer
um solely and entirely
used by the artificer
so the animal shape
the form that the animal has which
includes not just
its outward shape you know as if it was
you know
uh frozen in time by a taxidermist
but what it is that we're trying to see
about it you know if it's a jaguar
it's power and it's fearsomeness if it's
a lion another great cat which by the
way those existed in europe
and throughout the middle east and had
to be killed off um
you know another kind of fearsomeness
uh and majesty perhaps if we're talking
about the
bi you know the bison if we're talking
about the antelope if we're talking
about the bear
whatever it happens to be all the way
down to the lowly frog
well all of these things that are within
our sphere they're they're represented
according to their their essences as the
artificer
sees them that's the animal shape but
it's blended fear-mished
mixed up together with the shape
gestalt of thought
what is the shape of thought the human
shape
and hegel here you know there's a little
bit of
translation stuff that we got to call
your attention to
he says with the human form hegel
doesn't say the human form he just says
the menschleigh right uh the mensch link
in what
gestalt the the human
you know shape the human form the human
attribute so the animal shape and the
human are brought together
in important ways and this can happen
you know
through egyptian art where we have
animal headed gods you know for example
but
he goes on and he says this work still
lacks the shape and outer reality
in which the self exists as
self right so it's we haven't yet
reached the point that we
need to get to which will happen in the
next uh big section
he says it does not have in its own self
it does not in its own self proclaim
that it includes within it an
inner meaning what are we talking about
here
as an inner meaning well
being able to be an agency being able
to explain yourself
he talks about speech right
the capacity to bring forth
interiority into exteriority as we've
seen
throughout the phenomenology and he's
got this example here of this
statue of memnon right where he tells us
that
here we go it does not have in its own
self
speech the element in which the meaning
filling
it is itself present therefore the work
even when wholly purged of the animal
element wearing only the shape of
self-consciousness the human shape
right is still the soundless shape which
needs the rays of the rising sun
in order to have sound which generated
by light is even
then merely noise and not speech and
reveals only an
outer not the inner self it's very
interesting here right he's not
just contrasting the human
against the animal i mean you could say
well what about the animal the animal
doesn't have speech
except that when we give it to them like
in cartoons or you know
legendary stories or grimm's fairy tales
or stuff like that
here he's talking about representation
though the
statue of the human being that has the
human form
that has a face
that can actually make a sound there's
this famous statue it was one of the you
know
great wonders of the world where the sun
would shine on it
and at a certain part of the day it
would it would make a sound it could be
there were a lot of descriptions of this
sound in the ancient world might have
just been a
purely sort of mechanical thing
happening
some people described it as a groan but
a groan is not yet
speech saying words like i'm saying to
you
or like hegel has written in this book
i mean hegel didn't write him in this
book miller translated this book
which is taking speech and making speech
right a certain kind of
uh craft work there but you get the idea
we're not yet where we need to be but
we're getting closer
now we're able to incorporate the animal
form and not in the same way that animal
religion did
now the animal and the human are
becoming part of
our panoply of you know architecture
statues
you know paintings other depictions as
well other representations
other for stellangen and so
you know we're trying to get to this
point where we can actually have
a revelation of the inner self
over against this outer shape of the
self stands the other shape which
proclaims its possession of an
inner being nature withdrawing into its
essence
deposes its living self-particularizing
self-entangling manifold existence
to the level of an unessential husk
which is the
covering for the inner being and this
inner being
is in the first instance still simple
darkness
the unmoved the black formless stone
the black stone and the kabbah at mecca
paragraph 696 introduces
an alternative to the statue
of the human being that has no no real
interiority as the human being
as the product of the worker who is a
human being
a spiritless outer shape so he tells us
over against this outer shape of the
self which is
you know a shape of a self but not a
shape of
the self maybe you could even say well
could it be the the self
of the artificer
sure but it's still just an outer form
and it lacks self hood
so over against this outer shape of the
self he says
stands the other shape which proclaims
its possession of an inner being so what
we have here now is
an alternative type of
created object a formed
object a worked upon thing
and this is not going to be successful
at this point right
the problem with this outer shape
present in for example the statue of
memnon that
makes a noise but doesn't actually have
speech is that it has no interiority as
human it's all pure exteriority
you can break it apart but you're not
going to get anything
there's no soul there's only body there
now the other shape that he talks about
really there's there's two ways to
conceive of this
one is that what he's talking about here
is life itself right he says
nature withdrawing institut into its
essence
deposes its living self-particularizing
self-entangling manifold existence to
the level
of an inessential husk so all of this
stuff you know think about you know the
animal
world right living self particularizing
self entangling
manifold existence a multiplicity is
another way of translating
manifold this this dynamic interaction
that's just the outer husk that's the
body and then what would be
the interiority the
soul well he tells us the there's an
inner being to this
what would the inner being be well
at least in this paragraph and this is
not just where we're going to remain but
this is where we are in this paragraph
he says it is in the first instance
simple darkness simple you know shadow
simple uh lack of
light finsterness right einfach
finsterness actually
and then he talks about and it's not
quite clear what he wants us to
make of this a black schwarz formless
just formless uh stone
now miller suggests that this should be
understood as the black stone and the
kebab
at mecca the kebab is this you know sort
of uh
construction the black stone
is one item within it
it's you know a meteorite um
and it's you know it's been in there
there have been a couple times where it
was stolen and
well only once actually where it was
stolen but
um is this really what hegel means
i mean all we know is that this stone
that's being mentioned and it might be
just being mentioned as an example
rather than
as the exemplification of this um
all we know about it is it's black and
formless formless could just mean
it doesn't have any determinate shape
it's not a cube it's not a
uh you know circle or sphere or
you know uh ovaloid like an egg or
anything like that it's just kind of
jumbled up together i mean that could
describe a meteor right it could also
describe a
big piece of basalt that's been brought
out we don't we don't really know
and so i think we don't have to go
beyond the text
at this point into miller's bracketing
of the black stone and the kabot
mecca we can just say look
you know the inner being here
is not something that can actually
provide us with the
self that we're looking for
both representations contain inwardness
and outer existence
the two moments of spirit and both
representations
contain the two moments at once in an
antithetical relation
the self both as inner and as outer
the two have to be united the soul of
the statue in human shape does not yet
come forth from the inner being
is not yet speech the outer existence
that
is in its own self inward and the inner
being of multi-form existence
is still soundless is not imminently
differentiated
and is still separated from its outer
existence
to which all differences belong the
artificer therefore unites the two by
blending the natural and the
self-conscious
shape and this ambiguous being which is
a riddle to itself
the conscious wrestling with the
non-conscious the simple inner with the
multi-form
outer the darkness of thought mating
with the clarity of utterance these
break out
into the language of a profound but
scarcely intelligible
wisdom
paragraph 697 now is a very important
transition point in part because
hegel is bringing together what we had
articulated in the two previous
paragraphs
as kind of being dead ends and showing
that they can be
turned into something that's that's not
a dead end but
actually or not an impasse but a way
forward and a way forward for
the the artificer to turn
into in the next paragraph an artist
so this is a really important
development he tells us that both of
these representations
the representations being talked about
in 695 with the statue
and this life this this you know living
self-particularizing self-entangling
manifold
existence in 696. by the way too
i want to mention uh the the german word
here is not for
stellogen it's darstellum right so
it's still the same um root
putting forward setting out uh
instead of four which we get
representation from
darsh telling so something is like being
really like put in our face right it's
there so these these two representations
they
both as he says contain inwardness and
outer existence these two move
moments of spirit and both of them
contain the two moments at the same time
in what he calls an
antithetical relation but zeongan
right that is and gagan gazeta so
they are they're not antithetical in the
sense of being like
opposites they're not antithetical in
the sense of being
logically uh you know contrasted to each
other
they're literally set against each other
so there's a spatiality to this
suggested that we're getting this
antithesis in
but it's an interesting spatiality right
there's the outer that you can see that
you can witness
then there's the inner that's supposed
to come forward that's supposed to give
meaning to the outer
but seems to be lacking in both of these
cases
right so as he says
this is the self both as inner and outer
and the two of them need to be united
now how are we going to unite them it
didn't work in the previous paragraphs
uniting these two
in statue in human shape the statue was
missing something something really
important it seemed to have a kind of
communicative power but that turned out
to be false
it had only a facsimile of communication
it did not have language or speech
right spracha the other one
the you know one that he's described as
living self-particularizing
etc etc he says
that one is is uh the inner being of
multi-form existence is still
soundless as well it's not imminently
differentiated
and it's still separated from its outer
existence to which all
differences belong so
they're both missing something they're
both
lacking a capacity to
you could say talk back to us the human
creators of them the gods don't speak
they just are they take our worship
and don't give us anything really in
return this could lead to a
you know saying why do we have these
gods well
here's where religion takes a new turn
according to hegel if
the forms of religious life cannot
themselves
open up their interiority to us and
speak
and engage us that way somebody's got to
give them
that capacity who's that i mean this is
kind of funny
why not god why can't god do it
it's the artificer it's spirit too
as the artificer but it is the artificer
who
is doing this so he goes on here
and he says the artificer unites the two
the two of these right
and he calls them the natural and the
self-conscious
shape and we should ask well which is
which
i mean you could argue both sides for
this
let's take the statue in human shape is
that a self-conscious shape
i mean yes and no
it's it's modeled after something that
has self-consciousness the human being
but we see the statue isn't
self-conscious it says the same stupid
dumb stuff over and over and over again
you know makes a sound when the sun hits
it it doesn't even like choose to make a
sound
maybe it's the natural shape but it's
not a shape of nature
except insofar as the human being is a
thing of nature yet the human being
is the bit of nature that can conceive
of nature
and understand nature so i don't know
maybe that's supposed to be the
self-conscious shape and this is
supposed to be the
natural shape over here the multi-form
existence the multiplicity of living
things but you know
we talked about the animal life as
being kind of like self-conscious this
is
you know i think you could make a case
for either side
it doesn't really matter because what's
really important
here is what the artificer is doing the
artificer
blends these shapes together
and he says and this ambiguous being
which is a riddle to it
to itself the conscious wrestling with
the non-conscious
the simple inner with the multi-form
outer
the darkness of thought mating with a
clarity of utterance now there's a lot
of stuff going on there right
so let's look at each of these in turn
the ambiguous being
right the ambiguity uh in in hegel's
thing is going to be framed in terms of
a duality right the ambi in greek
means you know one of two we
we say something is ambiguous it could
have more than one meaning right
but it really refers to a duo and it's
the same thing for the you know
ambigu ambiguousness or ambiguity in
germans by fault right it's two twofold
and so an ambiguity a a duality
going on there which is a riddle
to itself a thing to be figured out
the uh conscious wrestling with the
non-conscious
interesting to talk about that isn't it
consciousness
wrestling with what is lacking
consciousness but
perhaps could have consciousness right
um
what else do we have here the darkness
of thought
mating with the clarity of utterance now
isn't that
an interesting way to talk about we
usually think of thought as
illuminating right the darkness of
thought
the clarity of utterance these are not
even in the same register
one is visual and the other
is i suppose you could say clarity is
visual if you're talking about a certain
kind of like being able to see through
things
but we usually when we're talking about
utterance we're talking about
meaning right so these are being
united and it tells us that
these break into language
language is being supplied now by
bringing these both that lacked language
together the language of a profound but
scarcely
intelligible wisdom and actually the
scarcely intelligible
it doesn't quite convey it you know the
idea there is
the wisdom is intelligible only with
difficulty right uh cher festenliches
understood with making an effort
with overcoming some some
difficulty some heaviness right so this
language
is a really important step at this point
now the artwork
the fabrication thing is going to be
given
a kind of agency a kind of thought a
kind of
consciousness a kind of responsibility
that hitherto it was lacking
in this work there is an end of the
instinctive effort which produced the
work that in contrast to
self-consciousness
lacked consciousness for in it the
activity of the artificer which
constitutes self-consciousness comes
face-to-face with an equally
self-conscious self-expressive inner
being
in it he has worked himself up to the
point where his consciousness is divided
against
itself where spirit meets spirit in this
unity of self-conscious spirit with
itself
insofar as it is the shape and the
object of its consciousness
its blendings with the unconscious
shapes are purged of the immediate
shapes of nature
these monsters in shape word indeed are
dissolved into spiritual shape
into an outer that is retreated into
itself and an inner
that utters or expresses itself out of
itself and in its own self
into thought which begets itself which
preserves its shape
in harmony with itself and is
a lucid intelligible existence
spirit is artist
with paragraph 698 we now reach
a very important transition point we
are finishing up this small
sub portion which has been called the
artificer
right and that in turn is part of the
first
sub-section of the entire religion
section natural religion we are getting
to the
end of what hegel has identified as
natural religion and we see that there
is now
a movement past the
what we can call the limitations of
natural religion
and from this point on there's going to
be a more intense focus
on particular religions which are taken
as being you know
of universal significance so he tells us
in this work in the bringing to language
work there is an end of the instinctive
effort which produced
the work that in contrast to
self-consciousness
lacked consciousness so
we're no longer like a bunch of bees
building their hive
or people fabricating idols which then
don't speak to them and don't provide
them with anything or
you know more and more develop things
incorporating animal
shapes incorporating uh plant you know
ornamentation
crystalline structures none of that
stuff
really gave us what we wanted and what
part of what we want is for
god or the gods to talk back to us to
engage with us so he goes on and he says
that in this in the work
the activity of the artificer which
constitutes aus-makin right
self-consciousness comes face to face
with something that can respond to it
that can engage with it he says an
equally
an equally self-conscious
self-expressive
inner being that's worth dwelling on for
a minute
so the the work that has been
created through the transformation of
material
along certain lines that are provided by
the understanding or by observation of
nature
and the feeling that there's something
there's something sacred
in this now we've created something
that hegel's saying is equally
self-conscious
the god that i'm engaging with
is just as self-conscious as i am that
means
that that god is conscious of me
as another self-consciousness in
relation to it
and it's also not just self-conscious
self-expressive it's able to communicate
and and to respond to me
so he goes on and he says
in this we've worked ourselves up to the
point where
consciousness is divided against itself
and here he says
spirit meets spirit
so the artificer himself is spirit
and the product the equally
self-conscious self-expressive inner
being
that too is spirit spirit is now able to
meet itself there's a greater
feedback there's a greater communication
loop that's being generated
here and notice what's not happening you
know
master slave dialectic all these you
know unhappy consciousness
that's that sort of thing that's not
happening here there's a kind of
reconciliation taking place
so he says this is a unity of
self-conscious spirit
with itself and he says in so far as it
has the shape
and the object of its consciousness
the shape of its consciousness i i guess
you could say is both the worker
and also the worked upon thing that now
has an agency of its
own the object of itself consciousness
this is where it gets really interesting
we would say well the object is
obviously the object that is produced as
a work
but is it insofar as
there's an equal self-consciousness and
self-expressiveness on this side
the artificer him or herself can
also be an object right
objectified we say is a bad thing but
being
able to be seen as as
another human being or as another
sentient
being another rational being that is
what is being
provided here by this this process
so this is really in advance isn't it he
goes on and he says
it's being purged of
you know these these immediate shapes of
nature right
its blendings with the unconscious
shapes are purged
of these immediate shapes of nature and
he talks about monsters
monsters in shape word indeed are
dissolved into spiritual shape
into an outer that is retreated into
itself the outer still is there
but now the outer is a vehicle and into
its own self
into thought thought on the side of the
god
that begets itself which preserves its
shape and harmony with itself and is a
lucid intelligible
existence right so this entire
process this entire resolution
or reconciliation now leads to the the
last sentence
spirit this unity of self-conscious
spirit with itself in the artificer
in the work is now
a work of art because spirit now
is artist kunstler it's no longer
a worker it's no longer a
fabricator it's now an artist and
what does that mean well we're going to
get into this entire section
right of religion in the form of art but
looking ahead
art for hegel has a spiritual
significance that's part of what makes
it art it's not just putting nice colors
on something or chipping away at stuff
or
making you know molding things that you
can then say oh look that's cool that
looks like a bird or
anything like that there's something
more to it that makes it
art so you know we're moving away
from as he said this instinctual
activity towards something that's
more self-conscious and that expands the
realm of self-consciousness
into something that can ideally respond
back to me so we we close this section
now
for once actually having a real advance
and now i'm
ready to move into the religion
in terms of the work of art
you